hi
today we are going to talk about how you
can evolve
to a zero trust security model with
anthous
i am samrat ray i am the product
management lead for antho security at
google cloud
and with me is sandra my name is sandra
gua
i'm a security product manager for
google cloud
and today we'll talk about how you can
implement zero trust security
with anthony's but before we talk about
how you can do it let's first talk about
what is zero trust
when we talk to a folks out of outside
of google
we hear many different definitions of
what is zero trust
we hear terms like it's micro
or even nano segmentation right done
at the workload level we've heard terms
like perimeter less
um we've heard somebody say it's
something as an error was hey i've
implemented
mtls therefore i'm doing zero trust we
have heard
definitions from vendors and others
saying
things like trust endpoints and not the
network continuous threat monitoring
all of this is zero trust
so in order to make sense of this term
we decided that
we will give it a clear definition
rooted in
certain sets of principles as we
understand it at google
and then explain how we're implementing
parts of those principles using enthus
so how do we think about the term zero
trust
the first way of thinking about it
is to think about the term trust right
and instead of focusing on the word zero
because we all understand there's a bit
of a marketing spin there
we think about the reducing privilege
or trust on all production entities
right with respect to data critical
workloads and infrastructure
right so what we're saying is we don't
trust any one thing
it's not just about network security it
is bigger than that
broader than that we think about it as a
series of controls for defense in depth
and those controls include
infrastructure security
code or deployment security production
network access and
employee or insider access we have
described our approach
that covers all of these dimensions uh
through a paper
called beyond fraud and this has this is
available for you
to read we highly recommend that you
take a look at that
now let's talk about how we can take
these principles
and implement them with anthos
before we dive into the how let's talk
about another aspect
why why is this approach certainly
relevant to you
the reason for this being important
and gaining more and more relevance with
our customers
is the confluence of three technology
trends the first is
a hybrid and multi-cloud we are seeing
increasingly that the production
environment is changing from a single
homogeneous production environment right
without perhaps a single network
to a distributed production environment
spanning multiple clouds and on-premises
with different network architectures and
not having a consistent way of viewing
network security
right this means that your traditional
parameter based security approaches
no longer apply as if as well as they
did before
second is the adoption of containers and
of kubernetes
the adoption of containers in particular
implies that
your traditional security that was based
upon
securing the host and trusting the host
that ie at the infrastructure level is
no longer sufficient because the strong
correlation between
a workload and its host is no longer
true with kubernetes
therefore in addition to securing your
infrastructure you now need to rethink
about how you're securing your workloads
that are deployed to this infrastructure
where
many of those workloads may be deployed
on the same
node and a single workload may be
deployed on multiple nodes throughout
the screen
the last dimension is that option of
service based architectures
so we are seeing the breaking of
monoliths
into microservices this is great from a
developer velocity perspective
the challenge being you have now
suddenly increased the surface area of
access
in within your production network by
several magnitudes thus you now
need to ensure that you are properly
securing access
to sensitive infrastructure and to
sensitive data within your production
network and not just relying
on coarse grained controls that you had
before
so all of these trends together mean
that we need to revisit
how we are doing security and zero trust
is
a great way of thinking about how
security can be appropriately
appropriately applied in this modern
environment
so how can anthes help before we talk
about
what anthos does for you i just want to
set the context that
in this presentation we are only going
to talk about
zero trust approaches to production
workload security we are not going to
talk about
infrastructure security or perimeter
security you can apply
zero trust approaches to those
dimensions as well
we're just not covering them today we're
going to focus on workload security
so with anthos we enable you to think
about zero trust
along three macro principles the first
being
only trusted code and configuration can
be deployed to production
the second is that trust is not
associated with just the network
location of the workload but is actually
associated with
who the workload is and the user on
behalf of which the
workload is accessing any other system
on the production
the third is to make sure that all
service access
is granted to the right peer
and to the under the right rippers
context
so now we'll talk about how you can
actually
implement these principles in your
production environment
with anthros technologies and with that
i'll hand it over to sandra
to walk you through the anthos workload
lifecycle
thank you samurai if we take a look at
at a workload lifecycle it can roughly
be
categorized into two phases the deploy
phase and the runtime phase with
production identity
uh acting as a linchpin that ties
together
um the two phases so provenances
um can be tied with so with the right
production identity can tie together the
provenance
to the production privileges that a
workload
can assume and ultimately the production
resources
that the workload can access so
the goal for the deploy phase is to
ensure that only
trusted workload can assume the rate
production identity
then during the runtime phase making
sure that secure
accesses are carried out only by
trusted production identities if we take
a closer look
at the deploy phase uh we realize that
um production identities are typically
associated
with a scoped runtime environment such
as the namespace
or cluster then the deploy production
security goal
can roughly be translated to ensure only
trusted workload can be deployed
to the designated trusted environments
so what exactly is a trusted workload
so there are a common set of risks
associated
with uh deploying a workload
the workload deployed may
be built from untrusted code in an
untrusting environment
and the typical mitigation for that is
to make sure it's viewed centrally
and also make sure that it's signed by
the centralized process that use it so
that it can be verified later on
the workload may include a vulnerable
package
to help with that all images should be
scanned for no vulnerabilities
before they are deployed but that again
that is not sufficient
because you have to act on the
vulnerability findings
um by again signing it that verifies
that
the um vulnerability scan bar
has been reached before a workload
is deployed and then a workload what
about what about workloads that are not
sufficiently tested or reviewed again it
is not
sufficient that the necessary tests
are performed there should also be
evidences
um such as the signature that a workload
passes all necessary tests
once a workload is a pre uh is approved
for deployment
it may still be deployed with a wrong
configuration
um such as wrong as root that is why
it's
important to have configuration
guardrails to catch those mistakes
last but not least the workload that is
approved
for a while environment may not be
suitable for the other
um so it's important to have deploy
policies
that are environmentally appropriate uh
to only admit
workloads that are approved for the
target environment
in summary if we put in place
all these controls we should have
trusted workload
that are built from the right code
through the right process and deploy it
with the right configuration
to the right environment
enzos offers tools and products to
implement zero trust deployments
and all the controls that we described
in the previous slide
customer can choose to use cloud build
or other ci tools
to implement a centralized lock down csd
process
and they can build workloads using
secure
managed base images um that are
continuously scanned
and patched for normal abilities
once the image is built um and it gets
checked into
the container google content registry it
gets
picked up by the vulnerability scanner
um
google also hosts a container analysis
api
that serves as a metadata
as a container knowledge base
that stores uh metadatas bindings
uh build records um test results
so that all the information associated
with a container can be found in one
place for verification
later on once the image is ready to be
deployed
a key part of the security control is
a deploy policy final authorization
ensures that only explicitly authorized
image can be deployed
to the target runtime environment for
example
customer can set a policy
for their pci clusters to only allow
images
from a centralized build
pipeline that also meets their
vulnerability scanning bars
let's take a closer look at binary
authorization binary authorization
defines an attestation framework
using signature verification um
so csv components can sign or attest
an image as it passes through each
of the required stages in the release
process
the user can then require certain
attestations to be present
at deploy time to make sure that the
required stages
in the release process were actually
carried out
this mechanism allows the customer to
control
on what can be deployed in addition to
who can deploy
one may have different policies for each
of the production environments
for example customers may require images
deployed to the pci environment to be
signed off by the compliance
stakeholders in addition to meeting the
regular
test and quality bars for regular
production environments
in addition to signature verification
final authorization
also supports an allow list for certain
third-party images that are deployed in
the
user's environment the security team for
example
can make it explicit which third-party
images
and versions is allowed across your
organization
that makes it very easy to manage and
upgrade
and then there are also break glass
processes
in case there is a production emergency
and the workload needs to be pushed
without satisfying
the necessary release requirement
in which case the deployment will be
logged in autolog
and can be reviewed later on in the end
with the binary authorization every
workload that gets released into the
production environment
can be accounted for um it should be
either
built by the customer and signed by
their centralized
viewer and processors or is explicitly
whitelisted
from for render images or
if it's a google provided system image
that is
white listed by default using the system
policy in addition to binary
authorization
here are um additional product features
of ansels for secure deployment
the google container registry offers a
vulnerability scanning feature
that provides detailed insights for
known vulnerabilities
for checking images
once the initial scan is done it
continues to perform incremental
scannings
every time the vulnerability is updated
user gets vulnerability updates
even for images that are already running
enzo's config management makes it easy
to set up configuration guardrails
so it offers both customizable and
building policies
such as requiring strict mtls for all
services in a particular namespace
and then base managed base image are a
set of container based images
host on a cloud marketplace that are
maintained
and regularly patched by google they're
used for google's own products
and are good place to start when
building application containers
now um that we have looked over the
product features
let's do a quick recap so we take a look
at the
um working life cycle again a code from
approved sources are used in a
locked-down
centralized view process to produce a
workload container
and the workload container then gets
tested and scanned
for known vulnerabilities then as part
of the
the release process for that um
workload during the deployment stage it
gets
verified by final authorization against
a deploy policies
to ensure that it meets the customer
requirements
and has come from a trusted process
at this point the trusted workload has
assumed
the right production identity by running
on the designated
production environment i'm now
going to hand over to samurai to
describe
how to secure this workload while it's
running
thank you sandra we now have
a trusted workload that we can trust
in addition to just trusting the network
right
this allows us now to have a different
basis of trust which is rooted in the
workload
and its identity rather than
on just the network we will now talk
about how we can
leverage this workload identity
to uh securely grant access to sensitive
data and to sensitive
infrastructure in our production
environment
so how do we trust a production client
the way to trust a production client is
to
mitigate a number of risks associated
with access within a production
environment
these risks include access to payload by
entities listening on the production
network
it includes things like untrusted
workload
replaying application credentials uh
which
uh to gain access to data
right so some stolen application
credentials can be used to then gain
access to data which the workload is not
supposed to gain
have access to um and
so uh another risk that is there is a
client
impersonating a more privileged workload
right
and uh similarly um a
compromised client can not only
impersonate the privileged workload
but a compromised client can also
exfiltrate all user data
um that it has access to on its own
privilege lastly and an insider can also
gain access
to sensitive data and um sensitive
back-ends
without going through appropriate checks
by bypassing certain front-ends
right so all of this risks exist in
terms of access within
a production network so the
corresponding set of controls
that we can use to mitigate these risks
are
we can ensure that all workload to
workload communication is encrypted in
transit
to prevent entities that are listening
on the network from gaining access to
sensitive data and credentials etc
we can ensure that all clients are
explicitly authorized such that
untrusted clients don't gain access even
if they have the right application level
credentials
we want to ensure that when we authorize
a client
we are authorizing it based upon a
non-replayable attribute of the client
versus
identifying the client through something
like a token that itself can be replayed
right thus we want to prevent
impersonations
by using something like an ip address
or a credential that is based upon
a cryptographically signed certificate
for example that cannot be replayed
the next is we want to ensure that for
in the case there is a client that can
access pii
on behalf of an end user it can only do
so
when it is acting on behalf of that end
user
and not when you know if it's
compromised that it can gain access to
pii
without a valid end user that actually
has authority on that
data and lastly we want to ensure
that all insider access are locked down
to authorized clients that can implement
the right set of checks and obfuscation
etc before granting access to data
to earn a privileged insider thus we
will now talk about
how we can implement these set of
control mechanisms with anthony's
a key tool for implementing these
principles that we just talked about is
antho service mesh
we'll walk you through how anther
service mesh can help you
secure workload access followed by
access to data and to mitigate
uh in privileged insider risks as well
so the first step is to ensure that we
can secure workload access
without taking a dependency on the
security of the underlying network
this does not mean that you are not
securing the underlying network
you we still recommend that you have the
right kind of perimeter
security and uh have a minimum set of
segmentation
to for not south access ensuring that
your backends are not exposed to the
internet for example
right having said that once you do that
it
we as we described before that is not
a sufficient um for modern production
environments
so thus we now will talk about how you
will actually grant
access within your production network
context
so the first step is to ensure that you
can
um we only grant access to authorized
network peers right to authorize clients
and we recommend doing that
using a certificate based identity the
advantage of a certificate based
identity is that it is
not replayable because the
receiver of a certificate cannot replay
it without also being in possession of
the private keys
thus it prevents impersonation attacks
right and the use of mutual tls for
authentication
also implies that you get encryption in
transit another key property that we
described earlier
the value of answer service mesh in this
context is to automatically manage
your certificates and keys for tens of
thousands of workloads in your
production
the next step is to ensure that
you use an authorization policy
that can reason about these identities
and
in addition to that can also reason
about additional attributes
like namespace and ips as needed in
order to grant access to a network
player
answer service mesh provides such a
policy that is integrated into the mesh
all of this implies that your security
can be policy driven
and is not baked into the code thus your
application developers can focus on
business
logic rather than on security the next
step after having secured workload to
workload access
is to secure access to user data by a
workload
so in addition to ensuring that you have
the right client
in order to gain access to user data we
want to ensure
that the client is accessing on behalf
of the right
end user and we can do this by
ensuring that the client presents a
valid
end user credential that is
has the right kind of claims to access
the data on the back end again answer
service mesh
provides you with a policy engine that
can a validate
that there is a valid end user
credential that is being presented
with the right signer and that is
actually
has not expired for example and it can
also
reason about the claims in that
jwt credential to
ensure that the credential has the right
kind of claims so that
the data can be accessed based upon
what the end user has access to and
not on the privilege of the credit card
front end itself
the last piece that antho service mesh
helps you secure
is insider access with respect to
insider access
and the service mesh ensures that your
insider
can only gain access to the right front
end
because enter service mesh will grant
access to data
let's say based upon a valid end user
credential
and your credit card back end will grant
access to data
if it's a valid privileged insider but
at the mesh layer you can ensure
that this valid insider is actually
accessing the data
via the right front end such as the case
tool over here
which could implement uh obfuscation or
pii
as needed it will deny access if the
same privileged insider where to deploy
their own personal script
and then try to gain access to data
without going through the
case too a key principle for granting
access to sensitive information or
infrastructure
to an insider is to ensure that we
strongly authenticate the insider
and this is done in google cloud
platform through a product called
identity about proxy
identity aware proxy uses beyond core
principles to ensure
that the user identity is
authenticated based on multiple factors
such as the client device attributes and
ip address
for example you can ensure that you can
you only grant access to sensitive data
when the insider
accesses the case tool
from a well-managed corporate device
that is secured
this ensures that you're only granting
access
under uh to the right person via the
right front end
coming from the right um endpoint device
for example
so to summarize antos provides um
features for securing access in
productions based upon zero trust
principles
the first being amster service mesh
which provides mutual tls
for encryption in transit and for
stronger authentication and
authorization
and the service mesh allows you to
secure
access across clusters and across vpc
networks
it also allows you to secure access
based upon
end user context and not just on
the peer context identity aware proxy
enables you
to grant access to to your insiders
based upon strong authentication of the
end user itself
and based upon things like the device
context
and ip address for example it's
integrated with answer service mesh
and it can also support third party
identities so you can bring your own
identity provider
and use that with identity proxy lastly
one of the things that we did not talk
about before is kubernetes network
policy
it is still important in this context of
zero trust access
um because it provides you with a
segmentation technology
that works within a single cluster so
thus you can use something like
kubernetes network policy
to implement a policy that says
the front end which is internet facing
cannot directly access the back end
by bypassing the middle tier right
so this kind of a knocks out
segmentation can be implemented
with the kubernetes network policy and
it adds defense and depth on top of
what you have at the base infrastructure
security level
and the security that you implement
using anthra service mesh
to summarize zero trust production
uh security uh can be achieved
with three principles which is only
trusted code and configuration can be
deployed to production trust is
associated with workload and user
and not just with the network location
and
all access to sensitive data and
infrastructure
is granted to the right network peers
and under the right
user context thank you